بين ضفتين تعيش اوكرانيا هذا هو نهر
النيبرو شريان البلاد الاهم واحد الاسماء
الاكثر حضورا في جغرافيا المعارك
يقسم النهر خريطه اوكرانيا من الشمال الى
الجنوب على طول يتجاوز الفا ومئتين متر
منذ بدء الحرب شكلت مهمه السيطره على
النهر وضفافه اهميه عسكريه استراتيجيه
وافقت الوحدات البحريه في القوات
الاوكرانيه على اصطحابنا في جوله في النهر
يقول قائد الوحده التي نرافقها ان
البدايات كانت لتكون افضل بكثير لو تم
التيقظ لاهميه
نستطيع السيطره وصد اي غزو من ضفتي لذلك
فان السيطره على النهر تتيح لك السيطره
على مساحات واسعه من اليابسه
اليوم تنشط هذه الوحدات في مهام عده اهمها
رصد المسيرات والتصدي لها كخط دفاع اول عن
العاصمه اضافه الى دورها كمسار امداد سريع
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق اخرى
نستطيع تغطيه ثلاثه ارباع اوكرانيا
ونستخدم دينيبرو كطريق امداد للمعدات
والقوات اكتسبنا خبره في التصدي للمسيرات
التي تستخدم النهر تجنب الرادارات نستخدم
الرشاشات اولا لاسقاطها ثم صواريخ ستينجر
فان لم نستطع تتصدى الدفاعات الجويه لها
خلال جولتنا نفذت القوه البحريه جزءا من
عملها الروتيني تفتيش من يسمح لهم بعبور
النهر بعد ان منع اي ابحار فيه منذ بدء
الحرب
اظهر من فضلك الاوراق الثبوتيه واوراق
المركب والحموله
على ما يرام يمكنكم متابعه ابحاركم
كل شيء كان على ما يرام في هذا المركب لكن
المهمه مستمره نهرب احد الخطوط
الخريطه البلاد هنا في العاصمه تبذل
القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه جهدا كبيرا
لمنع اي تسلل نحو وللتصدي لهجمات مسيرات
تقول انها لا تتوقف
ادامبورينا الجزيره من نهر النيبرو كير
[موسيقى]